foreign
let's go out to California and talk to
the Great and Powerful Sharon what's up
Sharon
I can't believe that I get to talk to
the doctor
right now believe believe I'm believing
it I'm embracing this man right now dude
my kids won't even talk you're man this
makes me feel good I may call you just
randomly just so you can be that happy
every day anytime what's up my number
close by well
Dr John
I'm ready
I can't even wait this is what you're
about to say
full phone
no you're not
you aren't I want it okay
I feel like I want to be yeah there you
go sick and tired being on my cell phone
there you go I love that
that's huge okay why do you spend so
much time on your phone
feels like an escape it feels like this
sense of rest
like I'll come home from a long day of
work and I'll be like okay it's time to
take a nap
but it I will choose to go on my cell
phone instead and scroll
to get some sort of relief from it
do you have kids no
are you married
nope so it's just you the couch and the
phone
yep
do you have cats do you have cats or
dogs
um my roommates have three scary old
cats that I try to avoid do they call
themselves cat parents
you got to move out of that house it's
not safe psychologically for anybody
um
can I just applaud you good for you
it's awesome how old are you
I'm 20 27 27. all right so if you could
snap your fingers you get home from work
what would you love to have happening as
you get home from work
I'd love for the things in my head that
I've wanted to do to to happen say them
out loud get them out of your head and
say them out loud
the things I want to do if you could if
you you had a picture of what your life
would be like when you were 27 what was
it
I'd like to
uh to paint
to read to Adventure to get my laundry
done in a good amount of time
to rest and prepare meals and eat well
all the things you are saying are ways
that you love Sharon
so why don't you love Cher and that much
I think I I don't know I'm growing and
loving Sharon awesome
um
here's the deal I I wish this I could
give you some I've got some ideas on
what to do okay
okay but I want you to begin to frame
this as you're an addict
yeah I was wondering about that yes you
are a stone cold addict
[Music]
and that's okay because you know why I
am too
I did not have social media when I took
this job and now I even got a separate
phone to have it on there I told the the
place where I work if you're gonna make
me have this like a tool I need it on a
separate phone
and
I find myself closing my door to my
bedroom to be away from the chaos and I
just start scrolling
and so I am announcing that I'm an
addict too Sharon my name is John and I
I can't control my phone usage either
so we're in this together cool
okay sounds good so do you have to have
this like social media and all that
stuff for your work
no I don't okay
if you want to stop you have to stop
that means you gotta delete all that
crap off your phone
and I want to say I have okay deleted it
and what happens is I turn to like
Etsy or I go on venmo or I find some
other way to scroll
that even if it's not social media
can you leave your computer your laptop
at work
and here's what I'm saying at some point
you have to put some hurdles in front of
yourself and create some new habits
and it's kind of like if I'm telling
somebody hey dude the first thing you
got to do before you dig into all your
relationship issues and all the stuff
you got to quit drinking you got to quit
going to the bar and they're like yeah
but I'm just gonna like you gotta go to
the bar
for you it's going to be
um
not only just removing something but
you're gonna have to add things back in
now you call you started the call by
saying I am done with this and then like
you're like well I mean I want to be
done with this
do you actually want to sit home and
paint or do you want do you wish you
were the kind of person that was like in
a romantic comedy that came home and
painted
no I think I chose that as an
alternative thing to do what do you
actually want to do
I want to
um
I don't know there it is you don't know
and I think you've got some ideas like I
want to be an adventurer and a painter
dude I've seen all those movies too
Sharon but I don't think you want to be
any of those things maybe you do
yeah but my guess is if you really
wanted to you would be doing those
things
yeah that's true
like I really really love playing my
guitar and so I'm always having my kids
come downstairs saying dad turn it down
please you're not like you're not 15
again I'm like I know but I'm one day
they're gonna call they're never gonna
call but like but I I it interrupts
other things I'm doing because I like
playing
what are those things for you or have
you just created a life where you don't
have other things
I guess it's a journey of figuring out
what those things are that's the most
Millennial thing you've said I'm just on
a journey
another Swift in my headphones I'm just
on a journey
here's what I would love to challenge
you
I would love to challenge you for 30
days to delete them off and to sign up
for two different
classes whether that's a jiu jitsu class
whether that's a cooking class a dance
class something
that two days a week after work you have
to go somewhere
I think there's there's been some talk
and some discussion
um I haven't read the studies myself but
I've been the the conversations have
been compelling that
our current generation of human
especially 35 and younger
spins an inordinate amount of time at
home
everybody's just at home all the time
and when you're at home all the time a
there's no real romantic connections
there's no real friendship connections
that happen and the only thing you can
do is scroll and play video games or
watch Netflix that's the only thing you
can do because you're just a home
and so and yesterday I was playing Uno
with my daughter and there's just only
so many games you can play with Uno
before I'm like dude I'm gonna set these
cards all on fire in the front yard
right there's only so much of that and
so
um
I want to challenge you to be out of
your house
but but sign up for two classes for 30
days
and do two things that you're going to
be kind of uncomfortable doing it's
gonna be a little bit weird and what
you're going to do is if you do one
athletic thing and one artistic thing
and one this thing won that thing
you're gonna find out dude I am not a
jiu jitsu person or you might find out I
love love love love this
or I'm not a dance person or I'm not a
whatever so if I say a class like that
tell me something you'd be interested in
I'm imagining like a uh
maybe like a Ceramics or a watercolor I
saw a ghost too but I'm in I'm in
whatever it works my wife went and got
her Master Gardener certification she
just wanted to learn about gardening so
she just like went to the AG extension
building in our community and started
all I have to say is this
you can't just take something away you
got to fill it with something else
okay okay you also have to get radical
about your commitment maybe call a house
meeting and say I'm committed to
stopping scrolling and every time you'll
see me just sitting around scrolling on
my phone
I have to put x amount of dollars in the
jar
I have no apps on my phone anymore so
you have to text me you can't just DM me
okay and we're gonna have a group of
people over to the house once a week
oh I'm gonna make dinner for everybody
once a week whatever the thing is but I
want you to commit to doing signing up
for two classes of two things and do
this let me know how it goes
I would love to know what classes you're
going and then where what's happening on
the back end and that'll be your
accountability if you don't make it I'm
going to announce to all of America
there's not that many people listening
to the show but I'm gonna tell all of
them that you didn't make it you just
prefer to scroll your life away but I
don't think that's going to be you I
think you'll got it I think you got it I
here's my commitment to you
I'm going to commit for 30 days to
leaving my who this would be hard I'm
Gonna Leave My
work phone either at work or in my
vehicle I will not take it in my house
I have to get off of it I have to stop
um it's like one of my core thing
teachings and man those guys who create
those apps are good man they're good
they got me so I know I've made
commitments before and I've done them
for a few weeks I'm gonna make 30-day
commitment here we go and so I want you
to join me in this sharing
um I've got so much crap going on that I
can assure you I'll have plenty to do
after work but you got two things
and when you catch yourself which you
will that's okay
I want you to think out loud
Sharon is worth more than a numbed out
life
Sharon is worth more than a life that we
are just netflixing away
Sharon is worth Adventure laughter Joy
athletic Endeavors whatever the things
are Sharon is worth a life well lived
go make that happen
get one of your roommates to go with you
I promise there's Adventures on the
other side of this thing that are going
to be more valuable more peaceful more
healthy than
oh my gosh they're all coming to get us
aliens are real Bigfoot's not whatever I
don't know whatever you're scrolling
let's put them away everybody listening
30-day challenge put your phones away
put them away